il progetto genoma umano come voi sapete
è stato quel formidabile progetto
scientifico che ci ha permesso di
ottenere per la prima volta l'intera
sequenza di lettere di base si dice del
nostro genoma e con esso
naturalmente l'identità del genere
dell'uomo quello che però il progetto
giorno umano non poteva spiegarci e come
funziona il sistema è cosa c'è veramente
scritto nel dna lui dire perché per
esempio un certo genere è attivo in
certi tessuti e non deve essere attivi
in altri perché un gene che è rimasto
silente magari per anni in una cellula
magari un oncogene all'improvviso si
attiva e porta al cancro
ora rispondere a queste domande
naturalmente significa avere trovato una
chiave importante per affrontare
significative e malattie umane il cancro
oppure le malattie con gente voi sapete
per esempio che un bambino su 33 nasce
con una malattia congenita
in alcuni casi sono per fortuna con
effetti limitati sulla vita delle
persone
in altri casi possono essere devastanti
pensate soltanto per fare un esempio
alle deformità del corpo in altri casi
invece sono addirittura letali e quello
di cui vi voglio parlare io sono
importanti scoperte che sono state fatte
in questa direzione e gli ultimissimi
anni ed in particolare voglio produrvi
ad una nuova dimensione che è stato
scoperto nel dna la sua terza dimensione
il nostro genoma il fatto di circa 3
miliardi di base di lettere una
successione di tre miliardi
e lungo queste tre miliardi di lettere
ci sono dei segmenti che sono chiamati i
geni sono da parte codificante del
nostro genoma cioè lì c'è scritto il
codice che serve alla cellula per
produrre le proteine che sono poi siamo
i mattoni fondamentali che servono alla
cellula per funzionario col progetto
genoma umano scoperto che in realtà noi
abbiamo razzialmente pochi geni pochi di
più di quelli di organismi estremamente
più semplici abbiamo 20 mila geni che
sono veramente poco più di quelli della
drosophila il moscerino della frutta che
avete lista d'estate pro votare sulle
frontiere non solo si è scoperto che il
nostro dna
in realtà per la maggior parte non è
geni
anzi i geni sono una frazione quasi
insignificante lunghezza del nostro di
roma meno del 2 per cento
la stragrande maggioranza del nostro
genoma non sono geni e fino a pochi anni
fa addirittura chiamato dna spazzatura
si pensava fosse il relitto
dell'evoluzione e invece oggi si è
capito che lì c'è la chiave della
regolazione del 2 per cento e quello che
si è capito che un modo tipico in cui
vengono controllati i geni al 90 98 per
cento non codificante del genoma e
quello che vedete nella diapositiva cioè
si è capito che lungo questo 98 per
cento esistono delle regioni di
regolazione dei geni quelle in verde
dalla diapositiva e queste fisicamente
entrò in contatto con loro gene
bersaglio
in questo modo trasferiscono
informazioni sul suo stato di attività
se deve essere acceso oppure se deve
essere spento
naturalmente capite che è tutt'altro che
banale come fanno i due regolatori nel
buio del nucleo cellulare andare a
trovare il loro bersaglio e questo deve
succedere per i 20 mila geni del genoma
umano e dei loro relatori allo stesso
tempo
fatto sta che ciò che controlla
l'attivita della cellula e la struttura
tridimensionale
ma come si ripiega e quindi è cambiata
la visione del dna che non è più
banalmente una semplice successione di
lettere ma è quello più in modo in cui
si ripiega ed è anche un problema di
impacchettamento formidabile nostro dna
non è un unico filamento sono 23 coppie
di filamenti che si chiamano cromosomi
nessuno potesse mettere questi 23 coppie
di filamenti uno dietro l'altro fanno
due metri e questi due metri di dna sono
contenuti in ciascuno delle nostre
cellule
in particolare il nucleo della cellula
che pochi millesimi di millimetro di
dimensione
insomma capite non solo un formidabile
problema di impacchettamento ma da come
si impacchetta il dna si stabilisce
l'attivita che esso deve svolgere come i
geni non essere regolati e nonostante
queste le complicazioni e queste cose ai
formidabili che gli ho detto quello che
succede e che l'architettura del nostro
dna e stupefacente a sinistra nella
diapositiva vedete una vera immagine
presa al microscopio di un nucleo di una
cellula umana e avete capito che diversi
colori sono i diversi cromosomi quando
gli scienziati hanno scoperto questo
tipo di cose questo scenario hanno
letteralmente fatto un salto sulla sedia
perché capite c'è ordine i diversi
cromosomi non sono mischiati l'uno con
l'altro ma è come se ciascuno trovasse
nella sua posizione nel nucleo fanno una
mappa geografica e capite il l'opposto
di quello che uno si aspetterebbe
trovare in un piatto di spaghetti
colorati o impigliate gli spaghetti li
cucinate riversato nel piatto e si
mischiano e invece qua come se ogni
spaghetto capisse chiama identità sia
rotolasse in un gomitolo di andasse a
posizionarsi una particolare posizione
del piatto e gli altri spaghetti di
conseguenza insomma
subito salta agli occhi la domanda
fondamentale quale può essere la mano
invisibile il meccanismo che porta a
questa stop ascente organizzazione ma è
ancora più formidabile di così
questo si è scoperto negli ultimi anni e
qui il gruppo pericolo la federico ii di
napoli ha dato importanti contributi
cioè di recente si può cominciare
investigare cosa succede dentro ciascuno
di questi territori cioè dentro un
cromosoma e per farla breve quello che
si è capito che esiste una struttura di
domini dentro domini che culmina nei
territori che avete visto prima quindi
una struttura frattale come nelle
scatole cinesi o nelle bambole russe ma
voglio tornare alla domanda che ho
lasciato in sospeso cioè quali sono i
meccanismi dell'organizzazione e quello
che si sta capendo e che alla fine sono
concetti relativamente semplici e voglio
farlo capire con una una slide e un po
folle che riguarda le l'attrezzatura da
montagna alle corde la montagna voi
sapete che gli scalatori per tenere in
posizione le corde devono usare le ganci
e questi ganci serve appunto a fissare
in posizione precisa che una rispetto
adatto alle corde
oppure occorrono ganci che servono a far
scorrere in maniera ordinata
le corde una sull'altra a quello che
succede nel nostro dna
esattamente la stessa cosa naturalmente
ganci sono delle molecole e queste
molecole riescono ad agganciare i
regolatori e di gente pure ho parlato
prima ea tenerli in posizione in maniera
stabile affidabile così che le
informazioni possa essere trasmesse e
questi meccanismi creano e l'origami
straordinario che io vi ho illustrato ma
da un punto di vista della fisica
il dna non è altro che un polimero c'è
un particolare tipo di molecola ei ganci
sono molecole e quindi l'idea è che noi
possiamo capire come nasce quella
struttura formidabile che vi ho detto
partendo dalle leggi della fisica
esattamente come 300 anni fa newton
usando le leggi della fisica per la
prima volta ha potuto predire il moto
dei pianeti
la struttura del sistema solare oggi ne
possiamo fare con il nostro dna e
naturalmente sono calcoli tranne
ovviamente più complicate però noi
sfruttiamo la potenza di calcolo del
supercomputer che abbiamo a disposizione
oggi è quella che vedete ruotare nella
slide e la prima ricostruzione della
struttura del dna intorno a un genere
softline che è molto importante
purtroppo proprio e le malattie
congenite in cui dicevo ottenuta dal mio
gruppo di ricerca a queste scoperte di
scienza di base che hanno cambiato
l'orizzonte con cui guardiamo al dna
e i suoi meccanismi naturalmente possono
avere grosse applicazioni in medicina e
voglio provare a descriverne una con un
esempio
pensate di avere un bambino un paziente
con una delezione congenita cioè a
quella persona manca un pezzo dna come
vedete nella diapositiva il pezzo
azzurro per qualche ragione è saltato
fino ad oggi si poteva diagnosticare
l'effetto di questa d'elezione se essa
conteneva un genere cioè se era un gene
quello che è stato attaccato dalla
d'elezione perché in quel caso di
qualche modo è semplice non funzionerà
più quel gene e il paziente sarà esposto
a quel tipo di di effetti ma i geni sono
il 2 per cento del nostro dna e invece
oggi noi possiamo predire cosa succede a
quel paziente
guardando alla struttura 3d che sappiamo
ricostruire sappiamo predirne e quindi
possiamo capire per esempio se una
delezione che magari non colpisce i geni
c'è quella d'elezione ha cambiato il
rapporto tra relatori e regalati magari
un certo regolatore non riesce ad andare
a bersaglio o peggio ancora come si
verifica in alcuni casi attivo non col
gene insomma la cosa formidabile e che
questo tipo di scoperte stanno aprendo
un nuovo orizzonte nelle possibilità di
diagnostica allargandolo in una misura
che fino veramente a pochissimi anni fa
era inimmaginabile
quello che possiamo fare oggi e prendere
il paziente il dna di un singolo
paziente e sequenziando interamente con
costi che sono oggi a abbordabili poche
centinaia di euro
non solo stanno vertiginosamente
diminuendo negli ultimi anni e questo
significa che noi possiamo fare
predizioni di diagnostica delle malattie
di cui ho parlato per il singolo
paziente non in media probabilmente
succederà questo ma possiamo dire cosa
succederà in quel paziente o nei suoi
tessuti
insomma noi vediamo la diagnostica
pronta da qui veramente a pochi anni e
forse non per la nostra generazione ma
per quella dei nostri figli
avendo capito i meccanismi alla base di
queste malattie
anche il trattamento e lo ringrazio
molto per farmi ascoltare